oh good morning Hank it's Tuesday I
didn't see you there I was busy working
on my new book in my usual novel writing
position anyway today's video comes to
you in four parts far one johning so the
nice people The Hollywood Reporter wrote
an article about The Fault in Our Stars
movie and me and they included this
picture and in longtime nerdfighter
Emily posted a picture of herself doing
what she called johning and then Charlie
McDonald did one and then began a
massive flood of johning including Josh
Sundquist and this very small person and
you Hank and lots and lots of other
people anyway Hank to catch the movie
thanks for joining us where's as do I so
I just wanted to say thank you for
joining or do your birthday Hank it was
your birthday yesterday happy birthday
unlike last year I did remember to get
you a present this year from me and also
from nerdfighteria the original arcade
game Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles TMNT
for life Hank this is a real tattoo by
the way is that weird also a guy got you
a donation to Partners in Health
Partners in Health for actual life part
three Hank green and the perfect
strangers it just occurred to me that
this video is going to have more than
three parts I apologize for that what
does my hair look so like weird and
grown up and professional Hank your
excellent new album incongruent comes
out tomorrow so nerdfighters that means
that today is the last day that you can
pre-order a signed copy there is a link
in the doobly-doo also for those of you
who prefer your goods and services
digital the album will be out on iTunes
tomorrow Hank I want to get all esterday
on you or anything but when I was
listening to the album I was reminded of
what a great musician you are in
addition to all the other things you do
and I really admire you and the way that
you go about your work I'm getting
yesterday anyway Hank long story short
you're not that cool you're a grapefruit
part for the many headless and/or
faceless people in my hotel room so I
kept doing all this like tiffy O's press
junket stuff with the cast of the movie
and they put us in a very nice hotel but
there are a lot of people in my room
with no heads this person has no head
this person has no head this person also
no head no head and then there are these
people who I think have heads but
definitely do not have faces this guy
has half a face which by the standards
of this hotel room puts him in like the
top 1% to face it nests part 5 tour so
Hank The Fault in Our Stars movie stuff
is starting to like actually happen now
like we just had our first screening for
fans of the book which was nuts and most
importantly they liked the movie like I
guess I want the movie to do well but to
be completely honest
you ultimately what I want is for people
who care about the book a lot to like
the movie and I got to sit in the back
of the theater for like the last 15
minutes of the movie and I heard quite a
lot of sobbing which I found very
encouraging anyway now starting today
actually I get to go on tour with
jaylene and Ansel and NAT okay for all
of these the doors open at 5:00 and the
show will start around 6:30 this is
Fox's tour not mine so I seriously have
no idea what's going to happen but I do
know that it's free today we will be in
Miami Florida at the Dolphin Mall is it
an actual dolphin is it a gigantic
dolphin that they turned into a mall
that seems like animal cruelty Wednesday
we will be in Cleveland at the Tower
City Center Thursday we will be in
lovely Nashville Tennessee at the War
Memorial Auditorium at the Tennessee
Performing Arts Center and Friday May
9th we'll be in Dallas Texas at the
Southside ballroom at Gilley's or
possibly Joey's like I said earlier I
don't know much about what's gonna
actually happen at these events but I
know there won't be signings because
they're just expecting a lot of people
but there will be like Q&A and general
merriment I think it'll be fun and
congratulations again on your great
album and thank you for being such a
good friend and brother to me in this
great but also very weird time of my
life dftba nerdfighteria Hank I will see
you on Friday